du carburant moins cher sur l'autoroute
c'est le pari que s'est lancé le
gestionnaire d'autoroutes paris rhin
rhône avec l'ouverture de sa propre
station service sur l'a6 dans le sens
paris-lyon ouverte 24 heures sur 24
depuis début avril
elle propose des prix attractifs aux
automobilistes qu'ils découvrent ce
concept unique en france
c'est vrai que ce n'est pas élevé
c'était plutôt un prix moyen qu'on peut
trouver en hors autoroutes
effectivement ce moment là j'aurais
envie de prendre mon essence sur
l'autoroute quand je verrai cette marque
là avec des carburants sous sa propre
marque
ap air air propose aujourd'hui de
l'essence et du diesel à 10 centimes de
moi que les stations services exploités
par les géants pétroliers sur cette
portion de route un projet sur lequel le
gestionnaire autoroutier travaille
depuis trois ans
l'objectif est de contrôler ces prix de
carburant pour toujours proposer la
meilleure offre à ses clients il ya le
coût du pétrole il ya le coût des taxes
qui sont complètement incompressibles et
après j'irai en limitant les
intermédiaires et en travaillant sur un
modèle économique le plus approprié sans
pour autant diminuer les services on a
on a souhaité offrir ce prix le plus
juste
donc il est réajustée tous les jours en
fonction des prix du marché
mais pour toujours être au plus haut
plus bas pour le
les automobilistes une enveloppe de 4
millions d'euros est prévu pour déployer
le concept d'ici 2025
ap air air devrait proposer une
quinzaine de stations service sur les
autoroutes de france